Oh, it's me.
She be mean too.
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hi, hi, hi, hi, welcome, welcome, welcome.
I mean, I mean.
How are you, how are you honking?
How you hunkin'?
Hunkin' good.
Hunkin' well.
How's your hunkin' with you?
I'm having a hunkin' good time.
Thank you!
I'm my mother man, thank you!
Hello?
Wayne says.
My favorite Goose...
Wait, my favorite streamer is back.
Goose Phantom.
I keep reading this as Goose House.
You know the Kimi da yo, Kimi nanda yo Ossie te kura ta
group.
I keep reading Goose House.
No advice for today.
I ran out, but I hope your throat is feeling better.
I have lots of fun at home at.
Thank you.
Can we get a Moe.
Moe.
Haak!
Oh, I forgot my...
My controller.
I feel like this is more of a controller game, right?
I feel like this is more of a controller game because...
It came out originally in...
What was it?
Maybe?
Haak!
Very much so.
Okay, cool.
Thank goodness they're a hawk.
It's better with controller.
Okay, cool.
Hikaru-na-ra is a banger.
It is.
I agree.
How are you feeling today, Minto?
I'm so good.
I'm so nervous.
I get nervous before, like, events and stuff.
So, and this weekend I will be at Holiday Matsuri in
Orlando, Florida.
And...
I have lots going on there.
I have a collab with a maid cafe.
I have a meet and greet.
I have a panel with Doki Bird.
I have a concert appearance.
And I have another meet and greet.
And I think that's everything that I have.
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you.
Now that you have a manager and team, would you consider
opening a PO box in the future?
Ah!
They said the...
they will they said that they will start accepting things on
our behalf I only asked because I have a Koharu garage kit
why do you have her are you sure that I can have her I got
my wisdom teeth removed and watching you makes me feel much
so much better willies feel better feel better well isn't
like the gas I've I want to know what I would be like on the
laughing gas.
Minto builds garage kits?
No, actually, I have like a couple that are just kind of
sitting in a box because I wanted to buy them.
Because garage kits typically, like, a lot of times it'll be
like figures of characters that would never, ever get a
figure.
And so I'll buy a garage kit of it.
And then I'll kind of sit on it and be like, one day I'll
take this to a hobby shop and pass it along to somebody who
would be more skilled than all.
my poor metal kit i know i wonder what i would be like on
the laughing guys they put me all the way out when i got my
wisdom teeth out still came halfway back during the
procedure that's scary that's scary one time i feel like
though i think i had a cavity and they were drill they gave
me the numbing and they drew started drilling and then i
kept feeling it
It's not quite the same.
Scary.
Nightmare, nightmare, nightmare.
It was pretty bad.
I was like, oh, ouchy.
Ouchy, ouchy.
Thank you.
Also, so many memos coming back.
Good night, Minky, and chat, because I have to wakey-wakey
in five hours.
Good night, Rafa!
Good night, good night.
You need to pay child support for all the people you got
pregnant from Santa Baby cover last year.
That's more than a year.
Wouldn't it be nine months?
Wouldn't it be if there were any pregnancies, but I've seen
no proof?
I've been told, oh, Minto, I'm pregnant.
Minto, I'm gonna have a baby.
Minto, you're the father.
But I've seen no proof!
I think I'm getting scammed.
I think you guys are all setting me up for...
I think you've set up this elaborate scheme where you rob me
of my money.
Which is kind of you guys' money.
That's how I make money.
Wait.
Pay the child support, Minto.
Minto is 200% baby, though.
It's been nine months.
Oh my gosh, Terry, it's been nine months.
I'm afraid it's been nine months.
Congratulations on the babies.
Where are they?
And don't be going to no cabbage patch hospitals where...
Have you guys seen that before?
You know cabbage patch kids, right?
They have this one place.
I forgot what it's called, but there's like a it's like a
cabbage patch kids hospital and you go in there and like you
see the babies little cabbage patch babies like They're like
in like the hospital rooms and then they're like okay The
the mother is going into labor now She will birth the
cabbage patch baby with the weird birthing ritual yes yes
yes baby land general hospital yeah it's it's so bizarre
it's like super strange
i don't like i didn't think cabbage patch kids were still
popular enough to have a place in operation like that this
is this just in florida made refuses to pay child support
for over 420k children no well actually the bond does not
have 400k 400 for 400 wait 400 400k 400k 400k views so
that's not how many people are pregnant did i make it in
time for a fresh stream you sure did welcome in Cabbage
patch kids are from 19 1890 wait 1980 why am I so dyslexic
today 18 no 1982 yeah but still they shouldn't still be
popular where the the location is in business is what I mean
one of my late sisters favorites to watch me play along with
Katamari and super punch out please enjoy the games
unabashed shot in Florida.
I will.
I can't wait to cause chaos and mischief.
Let's try it.
Oh, two player.
No, single player.
I'm going to go into the green book.
And I'm not coming out.
Hello, I've been away and apparently I'm pregnant this time
with 420k kids or something.
Oh my gosh, Octo.
Does anyone remember her?
Cabbage Patchkins created in 1892.
That's when Columbus sailed.
Let's play the game.
Here I am.
Oh, press X to honk.
Oh my god.
That was an audio.
I'll turn it up just a bit.
Oh god, the way.
Oh!
What's that over there?
What is that?
Hmm.
My treasures.
My prizes.
My prized possessions.
LT, the Benf- Oh, oh, L.
Sorry.
What's this do?
Ooh, I'm flying.
Oh, I'm intimidating.
B to use your beak.
Ah!
So cute!
Yeah!
Strut it!
Look at me on the runway.
Look at me.
Wait, what if I...
I take flight.
America's next top goose.
Wait, you want to be on top?
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Bum, bum, bum.
You want to be on top.
Wait, what did I say?
Bend down to pick things up off the ground.
Oh, you want to be on top?
You want to be on top?
Boo, boo, boo, boo, boo, boo.
The way he walks is so cute.
Hank!
Can I jump?
Can I fly?
I can sneak around.
Columbus sailed in 1892, so Americans were...
Found by good old Chris.
Mm-hmm.
Christmas.
Jolly old Saint Nick.
Yes.
This is the world's smartest goose.
Wait, open up.
Oh.
Good enough.
It was very poorly constructed.
Definitely not my fault.
Spread your wings and fly.
Oh.
Cute!
So, wow, I'm zooming.
That might be the fastest goose alive.
Oh, it's because I was hitting run.
Title car!
Oh, I'm stuck.
I was stuck.
It's implied your wings are clipped.
Who did this to me?
Is that why I hate humans?
Is that why I must cause them grief?
Who is here?
I like this.
I like that a lot.
Take revenge on society.
I'm an angry goose.
What's going on here?
I can't read anything.
I'm a goose.
Press back to see her.
Oh, to do.
Get into the garden.
Get the groundskeeper wet.
Steal the groundskeeper.
make the groundskeeper's keys, make the groundskeeper wear
his sun hat, rake the lake, have a picnic, bring to the
picnic blanket, sandwich apples, pumpkin, carrot, dam,
thermos, radio basket.
Can I hop over?
Oh, but I can't even get on it.
Hmm.
That'll be...
Yeah!
Now we're gardening.
I'm just assisting, honestly.
Grab him.
Grab his keys.
Did I get him?
Wait.
I'm running inside?
I can run inside now.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
Hey, hey!
Yes.
Pumpkin.
I need to take this.
This is very important.
Hey.
No, no, no, you don't understand, sir.
You don't understand!
Oh!
The world depends on me!
I wish I didn't.
Go with such a...
I want to get him wet.
Where'd the radio go?
He took it?
That bastard.
I did see some stuff over here though.
Hold on, let's see.
What we got going on?
Wait.
No, no.
Wait, turn around.
I saw like... Oh, here, here.
What did I need to bring?
Sandwich.
Oh, I do need to bring the basket.
It's mine now.
Finders keepers?
Run.
It's like such a wide turn.
What's he doing anyway?
What am I doing in here?
Make him wear a sun hat.
Rake in the lake.
Where's the rake anyway?
Oh, I...
Oh, oh, oh.
Thank you so much for that, thank you so much, thank you.
Tactical goose action?
You know it.
I suppose to get him to wear his hat.
Is it break time?
Uh oh.
Wait, we need to hurry.
We need to get, we need to skedaddle.
He didn't notice at all.
What an idiot!
NAHHA!
NAH!
What else is there?
Um...
The apple.
I forgot the apple.
Nice.
And the basket.
Yes.
Who's running?
Oh, it's my feet.
Okay, good.
Break status.
Laked.
Absolutely.
Okay.
Apple, devoured.
Pumpkin, carrot, jam, thermos...
Oh, the radio!
I think that might be the last thing we get.
The daily life of wild, Minto.
Sorry.
For my picnic?
I sure skip... Oh, wrong way.
Turn around.
Turn around, goose.
There we go.
I sure scared him.
I think maybe when we...
Thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
Who eats a carrot at a picnic?
I mean, it doesn't seem so bad.
Oh my gosh.
The widest turn radius ever.
What's that sound?
Oh.
Hello.
He's staring at me and I'm staring at him.
Oh my god, he saw me.
He sees me.
Hey!
This guy sucks.
Well, you know, we'll be perfect for our picnic.
Come on, please.
Let me play.
Oh.
No!
Did I break it?
Ah!
Uh-oh.
The music is so scary.
Oh, my God.
Go!
It's like a dinosaur!
It's chasing me.
Well, it doesn't work anymore, so I should be able to take
it now.
Sorry.
He's yelling at me.
Dang it!
I didn't mean to grab it again.
I wanted to grab his keys.
You failed goose.
What was that sound?
How does it still work?
I don't know, actually.
What is that?
Wait, what's that?
Curious.
Hmm.
What else do we need?
His keys, his sun hat, jam.
Oh, there's jam up here.
And the thermos.
I'm just looking.
I'm just intently staring.
I'm just...
How did he do this?
Fine!
You can have it!
You bastard, you... you...
When I get my beak on you, I swear.
I think the radio will have to be the last thing that we
grabbed for the picnic.
Oh.
Oh, I should have grabbed his keys just then.
Would have been perfect.
He's distracted.
Dang it!
Oh, I grabbed it!
I did the wrong...
Ah!
I got his keys!
I will never find them over here.
Okay.
Wait.
Is he looking for the rake?
You are so late, buddy.
Time for jam.
We're jamming.
Oh!
Close the gate, but then I can't get out.
I have to be able to bring everything over here.
Unless there's like a secret way?
Through the bushes?
No.
Unless I can...
Oh my god.
Yeah!
Oh.
Wait, maybe if I take this carrot.
Watch me take it.
Watch me.
Watch me take a carrot.
Look, look, look.
Yeah!
Lock the groundskeeper out of the garden.
Wait, was that... Oh my gosh!
It's a hidden objective!
For everybody who's especially evil.
What does he do now?
Wait.
Well, I know what I must do.
I must continue my picnic.
No, he's gonna steal!
What are you gonna do with it?
What are you gonna do with it, huh?
Be honest.
Oh, wrong way.
Oh, I wrong way.
I went the wrong way.
I think he forgot.
Wait, how do I get to my other...
Oh, there we go.
Oh, pumpkin thermos radio.
Awesome.
Okay, through here, my hidey hole.
Perfect.
Will a pumpkin fit through my hole?
Now is the true test.
Oh, but it's heavy.
No!
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, he gave up.
He says, I don't have a job anymore, so.
I don't know why we're eating a pumpkin.
But I support it.
Okay, two more.
He says, yeah, he says, I'm no one now.
What's the point?
Is he trying to find a way to jump over?
Wait, what's over here?
anything?
beyond the sea Somewhere waiting for me I will haunt every
day and night And watching the world Oh, he's thinking of
that pumpkin Think of pumpkin I like this single one that's
growing Here, I'm gonna go give this to him.
Freak phantom can fit a pumpkin in the hole.
Oh, wait, I can't go through.
Wait.
Oh, a pumpkin can fit in the hole!
But a single tulip cannot!
Oh, this again.
He likes it.
That's my apology.
Wait, where'd the jam go?
Oh, I took the jam.
That's my bad.
Sorry.
Wait, get that thermos.
There we go.
How nice of it to give you a flower.
Exactly.
I'm a very thoughtful goose.
Don't look at me.
Don't perceive me.
Sneak.
Snake.
I'm like a snake in the water.
Sneaking around.
Oh, wrong way.
Turn around.
I think I'll ever find his keys
That one was pretty clean.
A liquid snake, if you will.
Where is he, anyway?
He's lost the will to live.
My bad.
Me, don't mean to honking so loudly and stealing so
stealthily.
What is your wisdom of the day?
It's better to live.
Oh, wait, I didn't put on his sun hat!
we didn't make the groundskeeper wear so okay we'll have to
do our picnic and then do that um it is better to have
honked than to never have honked at all happy holidays me
though happy holidays
easy this is like a great advertising for this little radio
here.
It's waterproof.
I knew what to do with this item.
Make the groundskeeper hammer his thumb.
We're trying to inflict violence on him.
Watching you on the big screen that my toddler watered
watered and waddled over.
When you heard your voice, I think my wife has been watching
you while I'm at work.
Hello, baby!
Hello baby.
Baby.
Boah.
Oh, I'm tiny.
Wait, what am I about?
Hello baby.
Baby.
Baby, baby, baby.
That's what you are.
You are a baby.
Baby,
do you want to see a trick?
Meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow,
meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Okay, I will take your...
I'll consider your super chat of your babysitting payment.
Covering my eyes and going, Where's the bingo?
Got your nose!
Priceless content.
Wait, can I open it too?
Or is it locked?
Oh, okay.
I gotta get the keys, maybe.
Or I can go inside and unlock it.
You need to hammer.
You need to get back to work, mister.
You're never gonna get paid.
What will your wife think?
How do I get inside?
There we go.
Just got home from work.
I'm much confused.
Hello!
Don't be confused.
It's just a baby.
Uh-oh.
Oh no, I think I need the keys.
Wait, maybe I just give him his keys back.
That's my Kamiyoshi.
YouTubers as children's entertainment.
I'm off to start an agency?
What would it be called?
I'm trying to think of like a VTuber teletubbies kind of,
you know?
VTubbies.
Get your keys.
Says, I don't know what those are.
Oh, yeah, you do.
Hey, don't get mad at me!
He's like, I gotta go replant this flower.
Oh, he doesn't know what to do.
His order of operations are all over the place.
Ah, the flower!
The caboose scares me.
I don't have object permanence.
Tell V tubbies.
Oh, that's good!
That's good!
Wait, please come here.
How do I get I get him to wear his hat.
How do I get him to wear his hat?
Can you grab the hat?
I'm trying to, but I can't reach it.
Oh, the hammer.
Is this what he's looking for?
The hammer in his little thought bubble looked different,
though.
I have to get the hat first.
Maybe I can...
But I can't jump!
I think they mean the one he's wearing.
I see.
Oh, that's what you mean.
So then he changes hats.
Got it.
Do you ever want a guest star on Sesame Street?
Yeah.
I would love to.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, I thought he was gonna bend over.
Maybe, uh, what can we do to make him bend over?
Uh, I think it'd be...
It's like...
You know the music in, like, Zelda?
Where, like, the...
The part...
Where it's, like, kind of frightening and, you know?
Oh, he doesn't!
Oh, he collects them.
Oh, then I'm actually helping you.
I'm assisting you.
Plant
it, plant it!
Will we ever hear your reasoning on Big Bird?
Probably not.
Not, yeah, when the Guardian, the Guardians, that music,
yeah.
What are you doing?
Mr. What are you doing?
Yep,
that works.
Let me just place this on this goose.
What's that?
No!
Hang in there.
Wait!
I gotta get his hat though, for real.
Was he changing boots?
No, he's just moving him around.
He doesn't know what to do.
I'm so confused.
Ah, sign won't stop goose because mint can't read.
Yeah!
I mean, what?
Alright, plant it, plant it!
I wanna, I don't think I have to do the last thing, though,
sun hat, but I want to try.
I don't think for all of them I will aim for...
Yeah!
I don't think I'll end for complete like total completion
obviously but
see you sucker see you sucker I
hope that's not his favorite hat imagine he's just like
that's the hat my great great great grandpappy gave me the
day he died and he said as long as you wear this lucky cap
no one will know you're bald
That would be so sad.
Hello.
Wise words.
And completion!
Complete the garden to-do list.
Let's go!
Onwards and honk words.
Hey kid!
You're afraid of a little goose?
You're afraid of a little goose kid, huh?
What, you afraid I'm gonna nip your butt or something?
You're afraid of all the rows and rows of teeth in my mouth?
You're afraid of how scary my tongue is?
You're afraid of my long neck going up your ass?
Come here kid!
Come here!
What was that?
There's something to grab.
Is it the kid?
Oh, wait, I think I can undo his...
Hey, come here.
Oh, he's...
Wait, I can take his glasses now?
Trip the boy in the puddle!
Gasly!
I got an extra...
I got an extra achievement for being extra muted.
Break the broom!
Trap the boy in the phone booth!
Make the boy wear...
the wrong glasses make someone buy back their own stuff get
on tv go shopping holy cow
hey what you hate me or something oh she does she hates me
she says no no no goose allowed in store all right let's see
what we got going on over here this is a pretty big area
though Mint was born for this game.
Sell the plane, that's what I intended on doing.
I wanted to put it in the basket.
Oh, my bad.
Is she gonna go get it again?
No way.
Is that kid still blind?
Oh, TV.
Is this how I get on?
Let me go.
Let me in, let me in, please!
You can't see it without his glasses.
I gotta give him a wrong pair of glasses.
Where is he anyway?
Oh god!
I'm reading this message, you are fated to be reincarnated
as a goose.
Again.
Is there any glasses in here?
A pair of glasses.
Did she hit me?
Oh, she just kind of sweeps me away.
Um, I don't see another pair of glasses.
Okay, hold on.
What else do we got to do?
Make the boy.
Uh, trap the boy in the phone booth.
I don't even see a phone booth.
Am I blind?
In the store.
She had a glasses stand.
She did?
Oh, I am blind.
Where?
I'm perusing.
I'm just stealing this leak.
Oh I see the glasses down, I see them now.
Hey kid, try these on for size.
Do they work?
Well, I guess I do.
You know the...
Oh, drill.
Today I learned my Oshi's actually a goose.
Why is he chasing after me now?
Oh, my handle was taken.
Happy birthday!
I want to say something.
Also, I'm sorry.
Well, I've been taken off singing happy birthday songs as of
late.
starting next year i want to start singing them again so i'm
sorry if i haven't sang your happy birthday song for um
recent but um yeah i will i will start singing them again
next year so i apologize if i missed you that means you have
to keep watching me until next year uh make someone buy back
their own stuff get on tv drop where's the phone booth Was
that over here?
This is a post.
Mail.
That's mail.
Top left.
Oh, okay.
Thank you, guys.
There's like garbage and...
Oh my god.
Nasty.
I'm disgusting.
I have a shield now.
Okay.
you can't hurt me you can't hurt me i have a shield oh my
god she made me drop my shield oh my god to battle to battle
can i like take like the apple and oh gross oh what else is
there break the broom how do i break the broom
let's see what could we do dude to break a broom.
Make the kid use the toothbrush.
We just hate him.
We're bullying him for no reason.
Broom to
if I were trying to break a broom.
I'm like, do I snap it in half?
But how would I do oh, I see the phone booth.
Hey kid, hey kid.
Hey kid.
Oh, how could I get him in here?
How could I even open it myself?
I was thinking maybe...
Take it!
Oh, no!
Please!
Please, please, please!
Let me in!
Scared him in there?
Oh, we could.
That's true.
Alright, let's scare...
Hey, no, not that way.
Oh, shoot.
Your broom is gone, lady.
Okay, wait.
Alright, come on.
Upwards?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, shoot.
No, please.
Are they like, come help me?
Yes.
I forgot how dynamic this game's soundtrack is.
I know, right?
How do I get on TV, though?
No!
Please, no!
I'm trying to get on TV!
What?
I saw it!
I could press it!
No, why would I let me press it before?
I was trying to get the button, you guys.
I really was.
Wait, I'm stuck in the...
Oh, nice.
Okay, awesome.
Wait.
No, please.
There we go!
Oh, it just...
Oh my gosh, just barely.
Holy cow!
We did it?
Make someone buy back their own stuff.
Oh, put in the basket.
Toothbrush.
Ah!
Okay, here we go.
That's why we need the toothbrush in the basket.
Okay.
What else was it?
Trimmed...
Oh, tinned food, cleaner, fruit.
Okay.
We'll just go find all this stuff.
Yeah, it was absolute clutch.
Oh, we gotta break this.
Okay.
No, no.
Please let me grab it.
Please, let me...
Let me grab it.
Oh, grab it, grab it.
Grab it.
Yeah!
Yeah, give me...
Excuse me, man.
I have my oral hygiene to take care of.
Let's go, let's go.
She can't keep getting away with it.
Oh, my depth perception strikes again.
Yeah, we broke it.
All right, next, loo paper.
Do you need to use the loo?
Let's grab the cleaner first while she's...
We'll let her be a little distracted.
I remember the cleaner over here and stuff.
Oh, not you.
I'm guessing this is the cleaner?
Toodle there!
Wait, this is not yours, is it?
Wait, is this yours?
It's not yours, is it?
Oh!
I thought you were gonna go the other way!
I'm gonna goose brush the teeth on its tongue.
Potentially.
Alright, let's get the cleaner.
Hey, kid, move out of the way.
I know I gotta do something with your dang...
Oh my gosh, I missed the opportunity again.
I gotta do something with this dang plane, or soccer ball
maybe.
Hey!
You stupid kid.
Okay.
That should be in there?
Yes, cleaner.
Do you want a hint for the plane?
No, it's okay.
I'll figure it out.
I don't think it's the basket.
I think maybe since there's...
See the toys right there?
There's like one spot open?
I think that might be our clue.
Hey!
I know you're afraid of me.
Don't even try, kid.
Don't even try.
I'll mess you up.
Ah!
She'll mess me up!
What else was there?
Uh, loo paper.
We can maybe grab that now.
Sneaky, sneak, sneak.
Sneaking?
Oh my gosh, she gonna see me?
Does that count?
Did that?
She took the cleaner!
Oh, I'm gonna kill this lady.
No!
Yeah, I think we do need to move the basket.
Otherwise, we're in trouble.
I didn't realize she would take things out.
Yeah, let's put the basket by the car first.
Best ghost?
Gim.
Natural.
Goose.
Me too.
We'll make everything soggy.
She won't want it anymore.
Okay, cool.
I'm just trying to be a responsible citizen.
And she will let me.
Wait, can I go under?
Oh, I can.
Awesome.
Oh!
How did she know?
Alright, let's go get the cleaner again.
Wait, where did she put it?
Also, is a...
Oh, what?
Fruit and veg.
Does this count as a fruit?
Or do I have to get a fresh fruit?
We shall see.
Oh, ha, me too.
Oh, ha, oh, ha, oh, ha.
That's surely she count, right?
Is mayonnaise a fruit?
Oh, she did put it up there, though.
She did put up the plane.
Okay, awesome.
Let's see.
Nice.
Hairbrush.
I don't know if I saw that.
Go buy your plane, kid.
Go buy it.
Hairbrush.
Oh, I see the hairbrush.
Dang it!
I pressed the wrong button!
It's fine.
We're fine.
Sometimes I like to just...
I gotta honk it out.
Worst possible time to honk.
Go buy your plane, kid.
Don't you miss it.
Maybe I gotta hide his soccer ball so he gets bored.
You know?
Oh.
I can't.
Wait, I wonder if I can...
No, no, no.
Hell yeah.
Dang it, okay.
Minto is extra cute today!
Here's some kawaii talks!
Alligato!
All right, what else we got?
Tinned food!
Tinned food.
Oh, here we go.
All right.
Our shopping is almost complete.
Some honkingly isom taunting.
Yes.
She never knew what hit her, honestly.
Yes!
Cleaner!
What did she do with the cleaner?
First of all, that was not hers.
She actually did steal that.
And it's quite rude.
What'd she do with it?
vegetable a leak is a veggie right we're going the long way
you saw it on the shelf okay okay good eyes good eyes
yes fruit and veg oh the dead apple count nice okay the
cleaner is all we gotta get I thought Minto was gonna haunt
me not honk at me.
I can do both.
Hey, he took his...
You wanna play?
You wanna play a game?
Do something!
We call it honking.
I love how whimsical yet sinister this game.
It's pretty sinister.
Make someone buy back their own stuff.
When is he gonna buy?
I saw it.
Hey!
I wanna watch.
Lure the boy into the store.
Is that what we gotta do?
I thought he would just think about his plane and be like,
Where is it?
Where could my plane be?
Sneak.
I like he's no snitch though.
You know what?
Maybe we've been too hard on him.
He hasn't snitched on me even once.
Yippee!
Did he get a new to-do list item?
Trap the shopkeeper in the garage.
There's a garage?
Run, kid, run!
Run to the shop!
No, not that way.
No, wrong way.
Run to the shop.
Run near.
There you go.
Oh!
Touching, baby.
This is money laundering, maybe.
Happy 4th of Hanukkah Minato.
Here's some guilt for my favorite ghost.
Thank you!
Happy 4th night!
Untitled ghost.
Ow.
Okay, where's the garage now?
Why did he let her know?
Oh!
That doesn't look anything like me.
You forgot my tail!
Trapper in here, huh?
Wait.
I think I messed up.
No, I think I messed right.
Wait, lady!
I can see it.
We wake up unable to move at the middle of the night.
The ghost made sounds at the foot of our bed staring.
Time passes and she opens her mouth wide.
I think I gotta let her know that I'm stealing.
Hey!
I'm stealing!
I'm st- Oh!
Wait, turn around.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, I thought I needed to really kill her.
I thought we were like, gonna trap her in there for real.
It's a free goose world, lady.
Was there something else that we didn't do?
No?
Okay, just kidding.
I got an achievement, but I guess it's just for completing
this area.
Nice!
A fine tomb.
This game is co-op.
It does!
It does, actually.
I can't say really I have the honkers for it, but I have the
spirit.
This?
Why do these people hate the goose so much?
Honk if you love maids!
Oh.
Is this a pathway that leads to nothing?
What do we have going on here?
Make someone break the fancy face.
Help the woman dress up the bust.
Make the man spit out his tea.
Get dressed up with a ribbon.
Make the man go barefoot.
Do the washing.
Oh bra!
Just the mint experience when you go...
It does look like a yaoi pet.
We need them to be thirsty.
What's wrong with being... Why do these people hate nature,
huh?
Is that the ribbon I want?
Oh, nope.
It's the ribbon that lets me inside though.
Oh, I want this!
Can you please put this on me?
Oh, she made me drop it.
How do I put it on?
Oh, I think maybe...
Okay, I think I know what to do.
I think I gotta move this guy.
She has no clue.
She has no idea.
And then I stand there.
Looking like a good goose.
So...
Wait, I'm the good goose.
No, no, no!
Please, it's me!
Will she notice, you think?
She just chucked it.
She was like, that goose is no...
Oh!
She really hates me!
It's okay for a lady with a goose in her yard.
You must really, really hate us.
You abuse that thing?
My god.
So rude.
She's chasing after me again.
I'm trying to...
Go back to your painting.
Is that the expensive vase right there?
Ugly.
I think it deserves to be broken.
Stop staring at me.
Oh, no, it's stuck.
Oh, it's stuck.
Oh, there we go.
Dang it!
The goose in your yard is probably taxidermy.
Oh, my God.
It's her own prize.
Terrifying.
Probably that frog, too.
Here, that fish!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Terrifying.
Yeah, get back to painting, lady.
We gotta really hide it, Will.
Alright, now take...
Take that part.
Yeah.
Okay, we're gonna sneak.
Oh!
She's gonna notice.
No, please!
Please, ma'am!
I'm your duck!
I'm your goose!
She says, you're still living!
Oh, that's cute.
Maybe if we, like, put it over here.
And then run back.
Oh my god!
My bad.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Now she'll never know.
She'll never know.
Stop moving.
Here we go.
What?
I wasn't moving for some reason he was.
I think he was getting impatient.
Okay, here we go.
This should be good.
Where is she going?
I'm so stressed.
This game is stressing me out a little bit.
Yippee!
Oh yeah.
Alright, what else do we have to do?
Make the man go barefoot.
Make the man's bed obviously.
Help the woman dress up the bus.
What's he doing?
Actually, how do I get back over to that side?
What's this?
Oh, it's really awful.
I'm so awful.
I thought she was gonna trip with the scissors.
Dress up the bust.
Okay, so we gotta find things to put on the bust that are
very cute, I think.
Need topside to go back.
Top side?
What do you mean by that?
Oh my god!
That scared me
Getting soapy How do we dress up the butt?
Oh, maybe oh wait the laundry where is okay, I think uh I
got the bra, I got the bra Oops, oh no Oh no!
She's noticed the bra is gone!
I'm not a pervert, I promise!
Just a little bit.
Alright.
What's this here?
Where is the washing machine anyway?
Ha ha ha!
A ding!
Where is it anyway?
Meep!
Sneaky?
She didn't find it, right?
She didn't find it.
How do I do the laundry?
I might be making this more difficult on myself by putting
them in a place that I...
Oh!
You guys need to take care of that.
That's, like, so dangerous.
Sorry, my bad.
I'm leaving!
Hello, sir.
Hey!
What about my ribbon?
You like it?
It's very dashing on me.
Is it not?
Yeah.
Uh, how do I give him some more soup?
Oh, I wonder if I put the laundry in here.
Maybe.
Okay, let's bring the laundry here.
Do I need the soap for it?
Oh, that's a great question.
Oh, I think I need to go around the other way, my bad.
Dashed and goose I've ever seen ever.
Yes, so lovely.
Are these people neighbors?
Are they like...
Oh, she...
Uh-oh.
Wait, what was it?
Make someone break the fancy vase.
She found the bra.
Or at least she found...
Oh, pair of socks.
Okay.
Oh, it does say bar of soap.
We gotta hurry.
No!
She'll never get it.
Now we need the soap.
Okay, nice.
But she found the bra.
I just don't know where she put it.
I mean, maybe she didn't find the bra.
She found the sock, at least.
She'll never get it.
You'll never have it again.
Okay.
Alright.
Yes, this is mine.
Yes, I am that size.
This is a nice...
Or a nice pair of honkers.
Don't mind the goose with the bro.
Okay.
Are you gonna give that to him?
What is he gonna do with it, huh?
you can look but you won't find it lady oh she's going back
for the bra it's a good thing we took it soap it up baby a
slipper a slipper oh we need one of his slippers oh he took
Yeah, we're gonna torture this guy.
Torture the hell out of this man.
Oh, okay.
I think I know what we need to do now.
Excuse me.
Oh, no, no, please, lady, please.
Please.
He's sipping the tea finally.
Oh, good.
I glitched through because I'm a genius.
I'm a ghost duck.
No!
Go back to your tea!
Honk with things in your beak for fun sound stuff.
Oh yeah, yeah, they're cute.
Speedrun strats.
Please go back to drinking your tea.
In fact, I'll take a sip.
I'll show you how it's done.
Sound warning, I'll turn it down a little bit.
And a one and a two and a...
Ah,
why does she have that anyway?
Help the woman dress up the bust.
Make someone break the fancy vows.
Got some pretty awful news from work.
No, I'm so sorry.
Pray for me to get a better job somewhere soon.
I hope so.
I hope you can get a better job soon sometime.
Oops.
How do I break the vase?
The vase.
And this guy.
We gotta dress him up.
But how?
With the bra?
And socks and such?
Yes.
I do the cooking.
I do the cleaning.
Yes, sir.
make the man go barefoot okay we gotta steal his other shoe
how yes i'm just a lonely goose please sir may i have some
more you don't mix colors and white hey i've never said i
was a perfect the pink is light enough okay The saw... Oh,
well, the shoe I cannot help.
I never said I was a perfect goose, okay?
No one taught me how to do laundry.
Dress up the bus.
Oh, I think with his stuff, I think, probably, you know.
Don't mind me.
Go back to your newspaper.
Wow, what a nice pipe you have there, mister.
I'll look away.
No, please!
Please!
Oh, oh!
I can grab it.
Good, she's oblivious.
Oh, yeah, I wanted to honk with it.
Oh.
I thought little bubbles would come out.
I'm a little disappointed.
That's okay.
That's fine.
What a distinguished goose!
Oh my god.
Please, sir.
Please, you don't understand.
If I don't do these things, they'll get me.
They're out for me.
Bubbles with the soap, yeah.
Oh, if I eat the soap.
You don't care about the soap.
This isn't yours.
Why is he being... Oh, that's yours.
Yeah.
I did take that.
Oh, shoot, please.
We're gonna hide?
You'll never know.
As long as you don't drop it.
Yeah.
It'll get dirty.
He has no idea.
Shoot.
Take
it.
And then please.
Grab it.
Oh.
I had it.
Yes.
I'm too good.
Who needs stealth?
Stealth is optional.
Get it.
And then get it.
Yeah!
Oh,
so cute.
Wait, I want to see her dress him up.
She's like, wow, so perfect.
Very lovely.
Love how she's giving back her stuff and she's using his
stuff to decorate.
Make sure.
We gotta make him go barefoot, and we gotta break the vase.
I don't think he's giving her stuff back.
Is he?
Oh, he is.
He gave back the vase.
Mr. Mr. Mr.
You took, you gave her back the most important thing.
How do I, how do I, wait.
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
How do I make her break it, though?
Oh, she's probably got to hold it.
And then I honk.
And spook her.
No?
Maybe I ring the bell, then.
Okay, I think that's what I do.
Come here.
What is this?
She just needs to add the bra and the bus.
Wait, I forgot the plan.
What was I going to do?
Wait, what is it anyway?
Make someone break it.
What if he...
Wait, uh...
Do I have to be super fast here?
Okay.
Maybe then I use...
Maybe I can make him do it.
Let's go, go, go.
Ow!
I didn't even need it!
Oh my gosh!
I...
Why would you do that?
Make someone prune the prize rose.
I guess... Oh!
He drew also.
He drew the best goose so far.
What a jerk.
I know.
I think they hate each other, these neighbors.
What a lovely...
Oh, I see what I have to do.
I see what I have to do.
Are they arguing?
The girls are fighting?
Perfect opportunity for me.
Oh no, yeah.
Your bush, whatever will you do?
Oh.
Wait, did she do it?
Oh, she's doing it.
Oh, my bad.
No, more, more, more, more, more, more.
More, more, more, more, more, more.
An eye for an eye.
That's what I say.
My vase.
Your.
What was the last one?
Make the man go barefoot.
It's okay.
I think I'll just continue onwards.
I do have a meeting tonight.
I have so many meetings.
I'm sorry, guys.
It's okay if we don't 100%.
Okay.
Hi!
You'll never see me again for now.
Oh!
So many meetings.
No, it's just that Densetsu we have.
So basically, we have a weekly one-on-one meeting and a
weekly group meeting.
And group meetings are on Wednesdays and my one-on-one is on
Sundays.
But that never, I never like streamed at the time that I
have my group, my one-on-one meeting.
Hmm.
And then we had to meet- we and the, um, Phoebe and Vicky,
we had to meet up to discuss some stuff.
Oh, oh, what did I do?
So, yeah.
That's- that's why- that's why it's like, oh my gosh,
there's always a meeting.
It's just- it's just us, like, checking in.
It's not always super important.
It's good to be there, you know.
Just in case I'm like...
In case there's something that I need to do.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la la.
Spread my wings, what?
Group meeting, gossip?
Dish, wait.
Oh, I know where I am.
Dish girl.
Okay.
So the tea is...
Oh, what is this?
Oh, there's a key there.
Or there's a lever there.
Yeah?
The T?
Oh, baby.
Wait, I want to try this one.
Oh.
Look how cute he is, though, is it?
What does that do?
Is this like a dam that will flood the whole city if I...
Or...
Maybe it will stop the water.
Let's go around.
Where did I come from?
Where did I go?
Cotton Eye Joe.
Hello, sir.
This guy doesn't look very friendly.
I'm just saying that now.
Oh, I knew it.
Oh my god, I knew it.
Immediately.
Immediately ousted.
What do you all have against the geese?
bit hard is it what do i have to do let's see get into the
park get into the park break the dartboard get the toy boat
make the old man fall on his bum be awarded a flower seal a
pint glass and drop it in the canal set the table oh oh he's
ready to get me he's ready to eat
Hello.
Just a box.
How would you know?
Not a peep.
Does it weigh the sound?
Is it the sound?
The weight of a goose?
This is approximately 1.5 goose.
Now that'd be just rude.
Where am I going?
The slaughterhouse.
Just a box.
But she'll keep that door open, right?
Dang it!
Where am I now though?
Get me out of here.
I should have...
Well, I think if I had honked, she would have thrown me out.
What is this?
Cleaner.
Break the dartboard.
Is there a dartboard?
What does this say behind here?
Like a sign there.
Oh wait, I think I can get in through here.
Wait, is there even more?
No, okay.
Oh!
There's so many people out to get me.
It's kind of terrifying, actually.
It's scary how many people hate me now.
Oh!
How do I get it?
How do I... how would I break?
Okay.
I gotta be awarded that flower!
Oh, what?
Yeah, there you go.
Oh my god!
Thank you!
That's so cute.
Wait, that was the cutest thing ever!
He's thinking cute.
I'm a showbird.
Look at me.
I'm the prettiest bird.
Alright.
Get the toy boat.
Toy boat.
able hey oh sorry i'm a showbird didn't you hear i'm a
showbird i'm a little i'm a literal showbird everyone's in
love with me now i love minke she's my favorite little dog
also merry christmas merry christmas thank you i think mike
tyson's ass thank you i think we maybe we break the
dartboard by throwing it throwing a fork at it instead The
goose has been irreversibly changed by the powers of idolu.
Steal a pint glass and drop it in the canal.
A pint glass?
Is that in the restaurant?
I'm not a dork, am I?
Sneaky, quiet.
Oh wait.
Is that the lady?
Who is cleaning?
That's the pint glass, right?
Oh wait, there's a knife too, maybe that'll break it.
Run!
Oh!
It made me break it!
Do I have to do my whole maneuver again to get inside?
How do I get inside again?
Oh, there we go.
How do I drop it in the canal, though?
Oh, dang it!
I just needed to be a little bit patient oh I have no
patience please please please I'm stuck actually there we go
snake maxing absolutely
yes yes yes how do I get maybe I need to distract him
somehow.
Fish and mailed.
And there was also a toy boat.
Your code name for this mission is Naked Goose.
Ah,
it's a goose.
I want to see what else is back here real quick.
That is definitely an anti-goose sign right there, though.
behind there that is absolute let's see is there anything
can i drag this no was there anything over here no my first
super thanks for spending time with us oh my gosh tj
autonomous thank you so much thank you
Make the old man fall on his bum.
Okay, I think let's try it.
Let's try and break the dartboard.
I think maybe, like I said, it's the knife.
In the restaurant.
Like, maybe we have him use the knife instead of the dart.
And it breaks it, you know?
It's just a box.
Just a box.
No.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
You never saw me.
Did I hear him on the harmonica?
Oh yeah, I did!
How cute!
Okay.
Maybe I can...
Oh!
No, the other one.
No, please lady.
Please, lady.
You don't understand.
Yeah, please, lady.
Yeah, yeah, there we go.
Okay, nice.
Nah, well, thank you so much for the tour.
You have to dance.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you so much.
Okay.
No, not that, please.
The knife.
Maybe it's not the knife at all.
Maybe I'm overthinking it.
Oh.
Or, um, maybe.
That's the toy boat!
No one ever notices the goose.
What has he got?
knife no don't
mind me okay say toy boat five times fast toy boat toy boat
toy boat toy boat wait that was pretty good
oh i thought i was joining you in your symphony
pull how does every person notice every single tiny little
thing that goes missing i didn't touch it I don't care about
your thing.
I don't care.
Wait, it was here, no?
Oh.
Wait.
I'm just taking it for the fun of it.
For the love of the game.
Hey!
How do I...
Maybe it's not.
How you break it.
I don't know.
Oh!
You're above!
Wait, is this the old man that I need to knock over?
That I need to make...
Oh my gosh, wait.
I think I know how.
Wait, that's so bad.
It's actually so bad though.
He'll break his... his tailbone.
So kind of funny though.
Fill in the blank.
Osla is to snake as blank as to goose.
Get pranked.
My mom would always be like, you cannot do that because she
knew somebody that that happened to and she broke her
tailbone and so she was always just like never ever do that.
That prank.
She said never ever.
I need that pint right there.
Oops.
Oopsie, oopsie, oopsie.
Yes, yes.
My parents said that about whipping people with towels.
What?
That would break their bones?
Okay, awesome.
Okay.
Alright, we got the pint.
Now what?
How do I very...
Do I hide in the box again?
You think?
Well, I think she...
Wait, no, she only carried...
I don't think I've ever seen a carry-a-box out on the end.
I don't want it to break, you know?
What kind of towels are they using?
Still a pint glass and drop it in the canal.
Oh, I bet she also turned off the water, I just realized.
Let's uh, maybe I can distract him and then go under here.
Oh my gosh, she scared me.
You bitch!
No!
It sucks when your tail breaks off.
Then it takes forever to grow back.
And it's never quite the same.
Yeah, it gets really big.
It's not skinny anymore.
So then everybody knows that you broke your tail off.
Get bolded.
No, she said calmly.
Oh, I think that was a valid crash out.
All right.
He's hard to get around, though.
He's tricky.
You can untie the guy's shoelaces.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm getting shooed.
Wait, what about when all the glasses are gone?
What do I do then?
Are there any left?
Uh.
I might just have to not do that.
that quest.
Oh, there's one left.
There is one left.
Nice goosey crash out.
Thank you.
Don't do it!
Please.
Can I hide you?
It will respawn, I think.
It will.
You think I don't think so.
Yay!
Okay, well we at least got this one.
Why do you care about this boat?
Break the dartboard and set the table.
That's right.
What table?
Oh, it's probably this one, no?
Knife, fork, plate, pepper, candle.
Okay, okay, we can do that.
Oh, there was a knife around here, huh?
Yeah, I stole it.
Where'd it go?
Where did it go?
Nice.
An eye for an eye.
Okay.
Never punished, everybody.
Monique!
Thank you so much!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifts.
20 gifts, thank you.
Oh my
goodness.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Can I get a hint for the dartboard?
I think that's one that I would need a hint for.
If I don't do the pint.
Metal goose.
Oh, and I've trained for this.
It involves honking.
Okay, cool.
I will remember that.
Plate.
There was a plate.
Uh-oh.
Are the girls fighting?
No.
They're just having arms.
That plate right there.
Hello.
They love me, though.
They won't rat me out.
They love me.
All right.
Our plate.
Plate, gitto.
Nice.
Top it.
You ruined my plans before.
I won't have you ruined my plans again.
Okay.
Hint.
Honk.
I love that.
That's a hint.
Uh, candle.
I thought those were ashtrays.
Are those candles?
They look like ashtrays to me, though.
Am I...
silly is there a candle what the oh I thought I thought like
a cutscene what is happening please no I'm trying to see if
I see a candle in there but I do not in an alternate
universe Minto played goose game before MGS or right now
she's honking while choking out guards candle is in the
corner okay I must have not seen it I'm just gonna casually
waddle up here.
Where is she?
Okay, wait, what do I...
A fork!
Oh, perfect.
Okay.
Wait, I'm not under the table.
Okay, be nice.
Nice.
Wait.
Okay.
Yeah, that was good timing.
I feel like I'm setting up the spaghetti scene from Lady and
the Tramp.
This is a knot.
What's that?
Oh, that's a toy boat that I stole.
What a beautiful knot.
Okay, candle must be the other corner.
Trust.
Can I pull that out?
See that cork in the barrel?
Can I get that?
You?
You!
You may have.
Wait.
Gotta bring the goose statue to that spot.
The goose statue?
What goose statue?
Oh, like...
That lady?
The one that had the...
The...
The garden?
Yes, I got the candle.
Oh my god.
You're really ruining my plans right now.
Thank you.
Do not...
Pay attention to the goose if the goose is not paying
attention to you.
Yeah!
Good enough.
Good enough?
Oh, this is a knight with a beautiful knight.
All right, let's go break that dartboard.
I give up on the pint.
I tried two times.
I know they say third times a charm, but I'm all the charm
that I need.
No, stop playing harmonica.
Hey, Christmas.
Happy Holidays!
Thank you, CJ!
See, Jeff?
It's my birthday!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh, that's it?
He's just gotta have a little breather, and then he's done.
You know?
I'm looking away, I'm looking away.
A one, and a two, and a...
Wait,
what's that on there?
No, let me have it.
Let me have it.
It's mine.
No.
What is it?
Drop a bucket on the burly man's head.
What?
That's what I need to do to get out of here?
Drop a bucket on this guy's head?
Why is he a gatekeeping the park anyway, huh?
How do I drop a bucket on his head?
Birdly man.
I thought I misread it.
And that it actually did say birdly man.
There was a bucket.
Was there?
Where are I?
A bucket.
In here?
Oh wait?
I see it!
That... Oh!
He's gotta get the...
Do I chase him in here?
She is doing it.
I'll take that.
Why do they have these signs?
It's my other question.
Why do these signs exist?
For me?
They love me that much.
Okay.
Just like that, and it works.
But what?
Do I get him over there?
Oh!
Don't you worry, you're a pretty little head.
Wait, is she getting the candle?
No heck in the way.
She just...
Oh, no.
She's getting the bucket.
Don't disrupt my dinner scene, please.
She's really tall.
My dinner seat!
I'm trying to get out of your way!
Please, let a goose live.
Alright.
I'm gonna wait until there's less people over there.
And then we'll hopefully...
How do I get him to run over there, though?
And then not chase me when I go to get the bucket, you know?
the city why do they have these signs mess up the apples is
that what i do excuse you
oh he has to return it
uh oh wait can i hide under the table from him yeah all
right good go get that apple tomato go get the
Oh no, now there's two of them.
Don't worry about the glass.
You don't even work here.
Don't worry about that.
Don't worry about it.
Seriously.
Tompo.
Don't worry about that.
Don't worry about it.
He's so concerned about everything, except the things that
matter.
I'm surrounded, I am.
Oh, there he goes.
There he goes.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes, you're very, very concerned about the tomato.
You're very, very concerned about the tomato.
Am I gonna?
I'm scared.
I'm scared she'll see me over there, you know.
You're very, very concerned.
Ah, ah, oh.
Does he got it yet?
Mr. I don't like the way my mouth just kind of hangs open
like that.
I mean, I am a goose.
Maybe I'm actually catching flies.
It's so quiet.
I wasn't in the...
Wrong person.
Where is he?
Maybe he put it in the wrong thing.
since there's more than one you know no he didn't where is
it it's gone oh shoot what'd you do with it what'd you do
with her where is she where is she he aided it
I don't blame him I eat whole tomatoes like that too Hey!
Okay, let's do another one then.
Leave a trail of them.
I don't know if that's...
Well, I guess I could try.
Right?
It's like...
Run,
run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Doki Bird is our...
Wait, but I think someone else will grab it.
I don't think we can use a...
I don't think we can leave a trail.
trail.
I feel like someone else will grab one.
Maybe not.
Hey, miss her.
Check this out.
Yes.
Let's see what he does with it.
Oh, he has his own box over there!
Okay, we gotta get rid of that box.
I was like, he's probably putting it somewhere else for
sure.
Oh wait, maybe he'll fill it up And then take it over to the
other side Maybe that's what we need to do Rather than What
I was gonna do was
Feels like We're battling the Brickster What I thought was I
move his basket But I don't think so Take that
I think that's the case, though.
Let's hope.
What was that sound?
All right, there's only a couple more.
Or empty his, so he needs to go get another one.
But these are full, so I feel like he would bring the full
one over here, no?
I don't know.
I don't know which way it is.
It's one way or the other.
We either got to empty his or fill it up.
Okay.
I've never played this game before, guys.
So if I'm doing it wrong, don't get mad at me.
I have no idea.
If it's full?
Or if I fill it up and And he does nothing?
Then what I know is I can steal his box and he'll probably
go get another one.
So that's what we'll do.
We'll figure out which is the method.
How could you goose incorrectly?
I feel like they wouldn't make you do this, but at the same
time, who knows?
I feel like there's just so many...
There were so many tomatoes.
but why else would they give you so many to pick up if it
weren't to if this weren't the case to take them back and
forth but it's like so many to take back and forth I don't
know it's a good experiment yeah we're experimenting
you're too cute to give mother also hi me though hi Eric I
drop and honk drop it like a tonk drop it like a tonk drop
it I wonder what happens if I honk with tomato.
Whoa, that was close.
No, sir, where are you going?
Over here.
Oh, my God, he's stupid.
The floor is honking.
Whatever could it be?
it's crazy how much beer is in that cake what a backer yeah
what a backer all right let's see was my hypothesis correct
my hypothesis was incorrect no
way he's onto you.
Operation Drop and Honk is in danger.
Now we do the opposite.
We just...
No one will notice the red spheres underneath.
Oh my god, they'll just rot under here and become smelly.
They'll rot, they'll mold.
We'll create a new colony, a new species from this batch of
tomato.
You ever feel like that when you have really moldy food in
your fridge and you're like, I'm another life.
Your maternal instincts really just kick in.
Metal Gear.
Mint Goose.
That's me.
Hi, Lord Crosses.
Welcome back.
Kind of, yeah.
Sometimes I eat it, too.
Oh.
The mold, mother.
Wait, I just realized.
Can I get through this?
With a little difficulty, but we can.
I wish there was a way to grab the whole box, but it does
not appear to be the case.
It does not appear to be a way to grab the entire box, if
you were wondering.
Which is crazy!
We've grabbed so many other things with our beak.
Mold phantom.
Same color.
Ha ha ha.
look
at all your things are gone
yes yes you notice it's gone yes you must go retrieve more
yes yes uh yes I'm just gonna go on ahead while he ponders
that oh my gosh she saw me my tomates yes yes he's still in
shock when will we know that he is on a tomato run
wait I just noticed there's a hole there do I see that in
the fence
Hello, ma'am.
Could you please leave?
Was that him?
Please say yes.
Please let it be him.
It was not.
What?
I'm gonna go through the hole.
I did it.
Can you take the empty box?
Maybe if it's empty, well, like...
Like, let's see.
Let's practice with this one.
It won't even let me take this one, you know?
So I'm not quite sure.
Yeah, it won't let me take the box.
Put one tomato.
A singular one.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
the other box but like how does that get him to how does
that unless the one beneath the bucket yeah I had there were
tomatoes that's where we got all the tomatoes you guys
maybe he wants one so he put one there I'm so confused.
Like, I don't understand this man's way of thinking.
What is the logic here, sir?
What's the logic?
Yeah?
Yes?
And he goes back!
I tried chasing him before with the tomato.
He just puts him in his own box.
I'll try lowering him to the door.
Maybe we could do that.
With the tomato.
Like I'll make him chase me.
And then drop it.
Oh my god, wait.
Oh, oh.
That might be the perfect timing.
chance!
Yeah!
Good!
Oh, what happened?
Ah!
Dummy.
No, you ruined all those.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Sorry.
Oh, oh, oh, sorry, sorry.
Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry It's a new onboard.
Oh my goodness.
Maybe I guess as usual I overthought the equation.
I overthought the situation.
Now would be a good time to throw the glass in the river,
that's true, but I want to move on.
I'm sick of this dealing with this man.
I don't want to do, I don't want to deal with him anymore!
Oh please, please.
Was that it?
Did he do the thing?
How do I move on?
Did I actually distract him so that he couldn't...
Maybe...
Oh wait, hold on.
I wonder if I can get in here.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, I just saw it!
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Where are we now?
Little people.
Get into the model village.
I'm here.
Steal the beautiful miniature golden bell.
I will.
Oh my god.
Now I don't even deal with real people.
Oh my gosh.
It's a maze.
why does this exist okay there's no
okay hello hello Mr. Gardner hello Mr. Gardner oh this is
all the spots that we went to Kaiju goose yes I remember I
just I put stuff in here.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, I remember.
And then this guy.
We're going to kill you.
We're going to actually murder you.
Okay, he's drowning.
Nobody help him.
Why is there only one objective, though?
It's kind of scary.
What is this?
Oh!
Yeah!
Knock it down.
Yes!
What's this?
Oh, whoops.
Yes!
Destroy!
Yeah!
What's our new?
And take it all the way back home.
Is this my goal the whole time?
Oh my god, wait.
How am I supposed to get through with this thing?
It's gonna alert every guard.
Our prize!
Game has morphed into rampage.
Goose coming through!
Goose on the loose!
Everybody look out!
I'm a goose with a plan!
Uh, can I get through?
There we go.
Ding-ling-ling!
What is this now?
A lock, huh?
Interesting.
Okay, if I don't run, it doesn't ring.
I won't.
Wait, does this take me home?
Take me home!
Contrary.
You can't take the shortcut.
Oh my gosh.
What if it's like Minecraft where they're like, Oh no!
The bell is ringing.
Something is attacking.
I have to go all the way back, baby.
I think from here, though, it's not so bad.
She saw the bell.
Oh shoot.
They don't want me taking the bell.
Uh-oh.
Okay.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, the tomatoes.
Oh,
shoot.
Oh, shoot.
No!
No, that's mine!
No, please!
Give it back!
Oh, shoot.
I...
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, shoot.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, okay.
All right.
Final level.
Boss time.
Okay.
Please, let me go through.
They'll never see.
They'll never know.
I wonder what's over there.
Wait, do I have to go this way?
I!
Where am I?
I'm lost.
I'm a goose, but I have no home.
I'm gonna hide it right here so I can look around real
quick.
Go goose go!
I want to make a wish.
Can I hit it?
Can I get it in that tiny little hole right there?
You see it?
You see that tiny hole?
I almost had it.
Make a wish!
Make a wish on a star.
Oh.
Rude.
Ash or smite or sure.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
At least I have no one chasing me right now.
Locked.
Why is it?
She blocked the road.
Wait.
Oh, this is the gate.
Okay.
Oh, she got...
Oh, she fixed it.
How sweet.
The rose is on the ground.
What's going on here?
Oh, they're patrolling.
Oh, my God, scary.
Wait, what's happening?
Oh, he's fixing it.
Alright.
Let's go get my bell an attempt.
Wait, I'm gonna scope out as well.
I'm gonna scope and see it.
If this is still a viable way of getting over?
It's not!
You're not gonna fix it, though, right?
How could you?
Yeah, exactly.
Okay.
Goose retcon, recon.
Not retcon, sorry.
Goose recon, exactly.
But they're gonna be mad.
I'm gonna be mad if they see me with this bell.
They're gonna be angri.
The whole town is out to get me.
Right now, guys.
No!
Oh my gosh, they're so fast!
They're so fast with it!
Oh no, it's been boarded up!
How does one escape?
I did not do any recon on this area!
Okay.
Is he gonna see me?
Oh my gosh.
Don't turn around.
I'm stressed, bro.
My pants are sweating.
I assume I have to get past him.
But he's...
Gotta bait him further.
I think if I...
Wait, he's gonna see it, though.
Loop him, loop him, loop him, and run.
Where's the way out?
Oh, there it is.
See ya, sucker.
I'm gooseing along.
Is it this way?
Let's hide our bell again.
Do some recon.
Goose reconnaissance.
We're right now.
Evil.
Evil man.
The music keeps popping up.
I know!
It's scaring me!
Okay guys.
Alright.
We just gotta get home.
Why is it so spooky sounding?
The music sometimes.
Oh, this is the lady of this, yeah.
The grocery store.
Oh my god.
Don't see me?
You don't see me.
Everybody in the town is looking for me, you guys.
This is so bad.
Everybody in town is looking for me.
Oh!
No!
Dang it!
Dang
it!
Nice.
They're faster than me too!
Trip!
Trip in the...
Ah!
Stealth is optional!
Oh my god, they're still chasing after me.
Okay.
They can't get in here.
But the...
But the farmer.
Oh!
We meet again.
Oh, the man.
We meet again!
For our final showdown.
He's waiting for you arms crossed and all.
He's like, I'm not even gonna...
I'm not even gonna search for you.
I know where you're headed to, you silly goose.
Ring it.
You are not smarter than I!
Old farmer!
Oh shoot, wait, my bell.
Wait, wait.
Yeah!
Wait, where is my home?
Take it all the way back home.
Where do I start?
Again.
Maybe across the bridge.
This way?
I think so.
La la la.
No, no.
Ah.
Oh, over here.
Take it home.
Take
it.
My children, I have returned.
What is this?
I have returned.
Wait.
I remember now that pile of bells.
No way.
Wait a second.
I...
No way.
another one to the pile
this ain't our first rodeo no wonder they hate me wait a
second I really have just been causing them grief this
entire time a goose as the goose
do you see why they have the signs
We have caused so much grief In this little city Oh my gosh
I didn't even remember the bell pile Until like the very
Last second Now go get the big bell Taco Bell No of course
we're not the bad guy Of course not She's having to return
everything.
Kodak ring.
That's the gardener.
They say he can grow anything.
That sun hat of his keeps bright light out of his eyes.
So flash bangs are not an option.
See if you can outsmart him somehow.
Oh my god.
It just shows your carnage.
I loved that.
It's so funny.
Darko, thank you so much for the pig.
Thank you for a honking fun stream.
You silly goose.
Have a great meeting again.
Quick cue.
Seeing goose's destructive behavior, I wonder, is it a baby
kaiju or is it an origin story?
If so, what will it grow?
What's grown-up kaiju name be?
I think it's truly shows how birds evolve.
from dinosaurs you know oh I can I can still hug I can still
hug another one bites the dust minto add it to the list yeah
oh here we go cabbage picnic make the shop scales go ding
open an umbrella inside the tv shop make someone from
outside the high street buy back their own stuff the high
street collect the five flowers in the basket over by the
well a tulip a late lazy sorry of the little lily a rose a
daisy and a chrysanthemum congrats on feeding another game
thank you the one with the telephone booth wait which one
the shop scales go ding so that's the hot slow one high
street is where the shop is the restaurant
oh my god there's even more trap the boy in the garage catch
an object as it's thrown over the fence get thrown over the
fence dress up the bust with things from outside the back
garden score Sail the toy boat under the bridge Perform at
the pub wearing a ribbon Steal the old man's wood Sorry Hat
To do quickly Oh my gosh there's speed runs no way
Cross out everything on the to-do list To do finally And
then there Some of these I didn't even complete like the
pint glass and the barefoot.
Most of them, most of them I did full, but it's the W's.
I'm sorry.
I think I have a trouble with the words that start with W.
The speedrun scene for this game is surprisingly complex.
I believe it because I feel like you Dude, it's crazy.
Even in bird form, crime is the way she flies to you.
Or she's flying with criminal events.
Good job, Rito.
Gustam hasn't slowed you down a bit.
Thank you!
This is so fun.
And like so stressful and relaxing at the same time.
Like it's just so cute.
Giant Princess, thank you.
I love the music.
in it it's just so nice is my picnic still here oh whoops a
little bit a little bit you didn't take everything if you
like silly chaos causing games like this i think you'd like
ape out it's a little harder and shorter but i think it was
made by benet fadi oh really wait i've heard of it before i
think maybe your picnic oh yes i brought i do the cook and i
do the cleaning i brought all the food to the to the picnic
that was so fun though that was so fun what a cute game
let's go assert my dominance one last time on the farmer the
gardener where are you where is he
oh no
The boy of mischief.
Yeah, this is fun.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you.
How do I...
Wait, I can't even pick this up.
Do I have to roll it all the way to the picnic?
No way.
Wait, I wonder if I can.
Oh, oops.
There's an attempt.
currently happening?
Wait!
Oh, I can pick up the bag.
Yeah, get through there.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll try one time.
If I get busted, we're busted.
Oh, it's a hill.
It's like playing soccer.
Wait, huh.
There we go.
Alright.
I don't know why we can't pick up the cabbage.
come on come on come on no please please don't go into the
water I'll cry um actually it's fruit bird fruit bird fruit
bird too heavy oh yeah like we've picked up heavier things
no all right some progress is being made oh my gosh oh my
god I think it might be easier if I use my neck okay here we
go like this yes yes we're doing it we're doing it we're
doing it well
i like how some actually all of the all of the extra
achievements i got were by accident no no no no no no no
it's okay oh my gosh wait okay we're so close you guys we're
so stinking close
cabbage picnic it's just the one right oh my gosh please
no please
okay okay now I'm done thank you so much everybody for goose
game I have you had as much fun as I did I didn't realize
that there was like a slight plot to this game i mean i knew
that there would be mischief involved but the fact that it
was the overall the overall mission was to get the bell and
return to our home is so funny it's so funny and i can't
believe i forgot about the bell pile even like even like
while i was when when it was like get the bell i was like
okay i didn't even i didn't even remember it it was so funny
thank you so much everyone thank you thank you i hope you
had fun and um i will be gone for a couple days but i will
still be streaming uh friday i'm not sure if a stream is
gonna happen i'll be honest but sunday stream will still
happen and then i'll stream um a few times before i get back
um so yeah
have a good day have a good night and i will see you guys
when i see you next Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
Have a good day, have a good night Oh yeah, tomorrow I will
be on Doki Bird's channel She will be playing Metal Gear
Solid Delta And I will be there for moral support So not a
stream on my own channel but on hers And yeah Yeah, yeah,
yeah, so And sanity damage Maybe, probably.
Probably, probably.
I think that was all I wanted to say.
If you are going to Holiday Matsuri, I will see you at
Holiday Matsuri.
And if not, then I'll see you when I see you next!
Win karaoke.
Sorry, I had to reschedule it until next week.
I'm sorry.
But it will happen.
It's just because I'm performing and talking a lot over the
weekend.
Conventions kind of tend to destroy my voice.
and I had a lot of recording before the karaoke so I was
like I think you know I might have to push it so I apologize
so but it will happen next week do not do not fret unless
I'm like sick or something but if I'm not sick then it will
definitely happen yeah okay
bye bye bye bye it's a day see you bye Bye.